the process of anybody great it's like
sometimes initially we play not to lose
right it's like when you play not to
lose you're worried about making
mistakes and then you make more mistakes
then you set up a game called like
playing to win oh I see these are my
opponents they they're firing me up
right and I'm gonna use that as fuel
here but then there's a game where you
transcend that called like playing for
the Love of the Game like could you see
like there's a possibility where is it
true that you wouldn't be inspired to
make real great stuff in the world if
you didn't have an opponent or could you
go out there no matter what court you
stepped on you were playing for the Love
of the Game and that's what people saw
really start to think the number you
have right the 35 million is the number
right I want you to go to that place and
just look from that place of what is now
possible okay what is now possible with
who you being in this place what's
accessible that isn't accessible now and
because we want to start pulling that
future into the present we don't want to
wait till then to do it so I want I want
you to create that place from the third
like I've touched 35 million that we
have the subscribers this is what's
going on in my world this is what it's
giving me access to this is who I'm
being this is what I'm doing and I want
you to like we're going to reverse
engineer it from there
how can I best be of service to you my
man the biggest thing is I don't know
what I don't know you know yeah and all
of these things so I remember when I
went to uh Napa every year Brendan you
know Brendan burchard yeah okay so every
year Brendan puts together a group of
his friends uh like you can't pay to go
you basically have to be his friend to
go so it was me and Tom bilyu and Mel
Robbins and Ed my lead and Lewis Hiles
and Jay Shetty it's Roundtable format so
everybody gets 20 minutes go around the
table ask whatever's on their mind some
people are putting the book some people
are figuring a work-life balance Etc and
when it came to me like you know you
guys know me like what's my blind spot
you guys I don't know what to ask so
pick me apart and like what's my blind
spot and then it was Tom and Lisa and
Brendan and uh Dean graziosi who just
kind of tore me apart for 20 minutes in
front of everybody which is great I like
it
so I think with all these things it's
like you know I've got my game plan that
I think is is working you know it's like
it's the best that I got for what I know
and who I am right now you know who am I
going to be yeah right but I mean I
don't know anything as at the same time
so
open open man open to the generosity
open to ideas open to new flavors I'm
just trying to change the world yeah and
you're doing it man so in the 35 million
like what do you think that's gonna
afford you like that that it doesn't now
because I know it's not only about the
numbers for you right but like what do
you think that's going to occur there
that that isn't occurring right now what
is that going to do is it access like
what are you looking
to experience when that occurs I don't
know and you know maybe that's a problem
what I know is I look at a lot of the
content right now what are my peers are
doing and it's all about the collapses
here and we're going into sterile and
like population is on the decline and
like the two sides are hating each other
it's just all negativity and I mean
that's that's not new but it's impacting
me more than usual and and I don't I
don't like it you know it's like okay
economic collapse is here or starting
great and like it's the greatest time to
be alive guys and it's the greatest time
to create more Prosperity than ever
right in your entire family lineage like
you have the greatest opportunity of all
time right yeah and so I just want to
get that message out
okay you know like I've I'm I feel like
I'm a lighthouse in a storm
and and I'm just trying to
I'm this little candle maybe not even a
lighthouse I like a candle in the in a
storm
really you know yeah well I mean listen
for the size that I've got it's great
we've hit you know whatever million
subscribers and half a billion views or
whatever but it's still it's still a
drop compared to everything that is
being consumed right and I'm not the
only one putting out positive content
but it but it feels like there's like
it's a one to one thousand ratio of like
positive to negative and uh I wanna
I want to fight that when you say that
it's hitting you more than normal like
it's it's impacting you more than normal
what does that mean
the people who
I respect both from a content creator
perspective and interviews and guests
like they go on people's shows are
increasingly talking about
negative things instead of positive
things and they're taking something
negative and like maybe trying to have a
little positive spin somewhere but it's
a lot more negative than it used to be
and there's some channels now that like
I used to watch religiously and like
just don't watch anymore because I feel
worse watching it you know like I get
consumed by like wait what is it why am
I why do I even care I don't care about
this why am I watching this thing yeah
um and it's working I mean the reason
why they do it is because it's working
because when they go that at that angle
it gets 10 times the number of views so
they continue going down that angle
right it's a lot harder to win being
positive than negative
yeah so is there any part of you right
that's like
man these guys 10 times faster because
they're going negative and I'm kind of
slow and steady doing the right thing
because this is what my heart says but
like
this this is how these guys are scaling
like are you feeling like
there's a there's a battle no
um
no the battles with myself that's like
man how do I make the light stronger
good you know like I don't know the
answer
um like and now that I decided I mean
Devin I decided that a long time ago
like the first top 10 video I did
profiling somebody was Kanye
yeah it's the top 10 rules for Success
from Kanye it was the top 10 stupidest
things Kanye has done
it's an easier video to make
it would get 10 times 100 times of use
because because we just love dunking on
whoever dunking on Kanye Duncan I'm Elon
dunking on whoever's president whatever
right uh and it's like I feel gross
doing that so it's like I don't want to
I don't want to do that so the fact that
my contemporaries might be going down a
more negative path it's like I
definitely don't want to go chasing down
that at all
um but it's like how do we make
positivity louder and I mean I'm I'm
fighting every day to try to figure it
out
okay all right it's it's percolating I
see it so I see a vision now one of the
things you mentioned you said it slipped
out of your mouth he was like I'm trying
to fight it right I'm trying to fight
against it now now you know I listen a
language one of my teachers was a woman
named Byron Katie she has this thing
called the school of the work right and
basically it's brilliant because she
kind of goes into
um
questioning unquestioned beliefs to turn
around right so she has just basically
four questions you know uh is so there's
this belief you have
uh the negative is outweighing the
positive could be true right so the
first question is like is it true
yeah yeah yeah I can say that's true Deb
right and then it's like can you
absolutely know it's true that negative
is out weighing positive right because I
could look and say I go to this family
and all that rocking is Evan right now
that's all they're rocking is my man
Evan so in that family I don't know if
it's outweighing I mean I don't know if
negativity is outweighing the positive
in that fit right so do we know it's
true okay say we say yes
and then the question is oh is this
when you believe the thought
well it's true or not when you believe
the thought
that these guys my contemporaries yeah
the negative is that I'm only a candle
in this world and and my light isn't as
loud when you believe that thought
how do you react
so think of a moment when it's like
this is happening I see my contemporary
I see it blow up right oh see I'm I'm
the light here and they're like this is
taking off
like how do you react in that moment
when you believe that thought that
that's really true so there's a
subconscious and a conscious the
subconscious is unease like here's
somebody who who's a trusted source for
me who I've I've Loved over the past X
number of years or whatever and I get
drawn into the negativity and the and
the talk of collapse and everything else
and then it shifts to like okay but like
now we gotta what are we gonna do about
this guys yeah it's like it it's uh the
the aggressive language I guess or fight
or whatever is a is like how do I like
take my candle and turn it into a
lighthouse or pour like gasoline and
like light the world up right the
frustration leads to
a desire to create Massive Action in the
opposite direction right so it's like I
see this I you know it's uneasy there
might be some judgment there and then
and then I use it to flip it around and
kind of fuel me right I kind of use that
to feel me so so same situation this
occurs these people do what they're
doing because people are always doing
the best they can with the thinking they
have if you if you thought like your
contemporaries they'd be doing the same
thing think about right like people are
always doing the best they can with the
thinking they have yeah there's a
thought right there's a thought like I
would just lay your values in there too
but sure right and values like look when
my my father turned our house into a
crack house when I was 16 right now I
had so much Judgment at first and I was
like how can he choose crack over me and
I realize at some point like my
grandmother passed and he took it a
certain way right and it was like wow he
was doing the best he could with the
he's clean now but he was doing the best
he could with the thinking he had so
what that allowed me to do is free
myself from you know any judgment and
all of that and and allow people their
process and if I was thinking like my
father I would have done the same thing
right so it's like this thing happens
Evan they're doing what they're doing
same situation who would you be without
the thought who would you be in that
situation they're doing what they're
doing same exact situation who would you
be without the thought that like they're
blowing up faster than me or I'm uneasy
about this or they're doing something
you know I'm a little like in the same
situation you see it happen but you
don't have that thought how would you
react then which thought am I
eliminating yeah the thought of
negativity is kind of winning the day
like that's 10 times faster than my
little light over here
okay so if I were to look out and see
just positivity everywhere it doesn't
even have to be positivity it's like
they're doing what they're doing yeah
right there's no unease they know that
shouldn't be doing this it's just this
is just people doing what they're doing
right who would you be without the
thought that there's something wrong
with it or it's winning the day who
would you be without that I mean it's
less that they shouldn't be doing I'm
not judging them for what they're doing
but who would I be
well how would you react differently
less inspired to get up and go
so you'd be less inspired
yeah
yeah so that's interesting so just
consider that you've created a game
right where you need this
to be inspired yeah I mean need is a
strong word but yes right the process of
anybody great it's like sometimes
initially we play we play not to lose
right it's like when you play not to
lose you're worried about making
mistakes and then you make more mistakes
right then you set up a game called like
playing the win it's like what would
playing a win oh I see these are my
opponents they they're firing me up
right and I'm gonna use that as fuel
here but then there's a game where you
transcend that called like playing for
the Love of the Game
right like like could you see like
there's a possibility where is it true
that you wouldn't be inspired to make
real great stuff in the world if you
didn't have an opponent
well could you go out there no matter
what court you stepped on you were
playing for the Love of the Game and and
that's what people saw like when I see
you
like dude the world needs more Devin
yeah and I do I can pull equally from
inspiring stories as well like man Devin
needs to get out there I need to share
more of these stories that I love
um but that wasn't the question the
question was like what would happen if I
didn't have that reaction to the to the
negativity if that happened and
who would you be without that thought
the even the thought I need that to be
inspired again needs a strong word I
don't it helps me get inspired right
like helpful I guess maybe it's like I
can pull from the two extremes where
either like I see somebody's like man I
need to put this person on where and
like help spread their message this is
crazy I gotta share this or man the
world is so negative I need to be a
force for good yeah uh and in the middle
I'm just doing my thing it's not as
inspiring because I don't see the
connection to the to the person right
like I love what I'm doing right I mean
we've done 10 000 videos it's been what
14 years of making content you know like
I wake up every day and I make videos
and we keep going right so I love the
process and somebody even asked me uh
there's a great quote about is it is it
the destination or the pro or the
journey and and the answer was it's the
company that you keep along the way
which I liked even better it's like who
you're doing the process with is even
better than just I love that sense right
and so on the days when I'm extra fired
up and motivated for for a positive or
negative reason I'm showing up with
extra fire and on the days when when
that's not there I'm still showing up
and doing my thing if we take it to the
extreme where
the opposite World exists where
there's a lot more it was a thousand a
one positive to negative
yeah I'm I'm probably chilling you know
it's like this is great I don't know if
I've been making videos anymore like my
it's like permission is complete like
but I'm not pissed about that it's like
I'll find something else to do like this
is this is awesome yeah like that world
ever gets created but I wake up every
day trying to make that world I love it
but in terms of like the I don't even
look at them as my competition uh
or any judgment for them for doing what
they're doing like like go I wish I had
more people I guess you know who were
who were fighting fighting what I see is
a good fight but yeah I take it more as
my responsibility it's like okay people
putting out negativity and even what my
contemporaries are doing compared to
other people is like vanilla compared to
what people are are putting out right
and so it's like instead of trying to
drown them out or say they're wrong or
censor them or whatever it's like how
can I just be brighter and more powerful
so you still give them the choice to
come to the light instead of go to the
dark that I believe people are good
yeah like I believe humans are good I
think if we ask if you went to people
and and you saw how they lived and you
gave them a chance to be good or bad I
think most people would be good and the
people who are bad or they're just in a
ton of pain like I think people are good
and I think people want good
but I think it's easy in human nature to
get pulled to
the negativity everybody wants to see
like the car accident on the side of the
road you know 100 listen I acknowledge
you for the mission or you know and I'm
glad you don't see him as the
competition because like what Byron K
used to tell me she was like sweetheart
defense
defense is the First Act of War
right because if someone's just doing
what they're doing and I don't get
defensive about it right or react to
this there's no war it's just them doing
what they're doing the moment I get
defensive that's when the war starts
right it's me versus them them versus me
and and you're too good man you you
you're such a bright light you have to
trust that
just continuing to create and make a
difference is having a ripple effect and
it is because everybody I know who's
experienced you is like this guy is is a
you know belief that's it like they talk
about belief and and the impact you've
had and so
I just want to encourage you like I
remember I went to this coaching my
coach had this coaching school and and
the first year I was there I was working
and I was transitioning and by the
second year I had taken off in coaching
and he put me on the faculty so there
was these coaches in there who were
there for like 20 years right like like
been in coaching for 20 years and
they're looking at this New York guy and
they're like why why is he on the
faculty and I could feel it man right I
could feel some of the hate right and
but at first it was fuel right I was
like all that's gonna do is make me be
even better right like I'm gonna take
that I'm gonna feel it and I'm gonna do
it but I always loved them right and
that's what I love what you're doing
with with your contemporaries and I
remember I got a call last year from
this guy from UK he's a really
well-known coach in the UK and he said
Devin I just want to call you I want to
apologize I said why are you apologizing
he said you know I I'm sure you notice I
don't know if you noticed but when you
were in that school you know back in
2013 like we we were hating on you man
and I wasn't the only one and people and
he was like I never it was amazing
because all you did was show us love
like you always made yourself available
you always right and he said and and and
I realized and all of us like realized
that like that was just our stuff and we
appreciate you being that bright light
right so like you look at there was this
group of people who was kind of in this
thing but it was really my light that
allowed them to step into and and seeing
who they're being in the world as well
and I think you're doing the same thing
in the world even though those people
may not be calling you and telling you
that yet but but I I would put my money
on well dude I've helped both of these
guys yeah like it's not leadership and
Entrepreneurship I've helped pretty much
everybody right right and even if they
have a message that is like way more
Brash or I don't know I'm a nice kind
Canadian you know like I don't swear I
don't like people like me right I mean I
have no enemies in the space there's so
much drama between different factions
and like who used to work for who and
who sold more books and whoever like
even in the personal development space
people are not living you know the thing
that they're preaching there's a lot of
jealousy like I'm friends with everybody
I'm friends with everybody I'm like you
in many ways brother and I navigate so
many worlds and personal development I
see that but like for me it's like I got
the same message it's like nah like I'm
the bright light in the world I'm I
illuminate every room I enter and I'm
here
my mission on this planet is twofold one
to love as many people as I can before I
die and I mean really love people and
and two like when it's all said and done
I wanted them to say like he used every
bit of talent like it was all left on
the court like there's nothing left in
the guy he gave it all okay and so you
know I see that in you man like you're
just such a
bright light and I think that
the path we're on the 35 mil and Beyond
we want to keep checking in on on those
limiting beliefs of it's not taking it's
not taking it it's taking too long or
it's not going fast enough like we
really want to slow that down and say
okay what is it here that we need to
kind of 10 times expand this and and
being because people are experiencing
you've helped everyone you've helped
everyone all these people in this world
yeah and listen I need I need like a pat
on the back one percent of the days like
I live in that zone like get me into
YouTube land thought leadership
entrepreneurship and I'll kick ass it's
like you know you're doing like here's
how we grow and I'm the most confident
you know human alive in my in my zone I
live there and so when I live there it's
okay now tell me why I suck it's not
that I suck I think I'm awesome but I
know that I'm missing a million things
but I'm not going home and then crying
in the bedroom or look in the mirror
saying like man you really suck like I
think I'm doing kick ass but I know
there's tons of other gears that I don't
know exist and that's what I'm trying to
figure out you know in terms of creating
the world of light right like
um I'm a very reluctant leader
I don't I'm introvert I'm shy I don't
like being at the front I I don't like
giving speeches I don't like being on
camera
um I I do it because of the mission
so you know if you and I are in a room
I don't see you as competition you're my
brother like right we're just doing it
in different ways right and your story
or my story or whatever like some way it
hits so if there's negativity in a room
and we're both in there and you want to
stand up and speak it's like I'm good
right like Devin's doing it right I just
wanted to get done right I don't need to
be the one but when there's nobody doing
it then I feel called that okay well
somebody's got to do it right so even
the Kanye thing was because my friend
that one of my closest friends for years
had this negative blog post that he
wrote about Kanye and Taylor Swift the
whole
Beyonce had the greatest album of all
time thing and it was like years after
that thing happened he was still talking
about it I'm like Mark dude
like you can learn from Kanye you should
learn from Kanye and so I I threw away
my day to make a video about Kanye
really just from my friend Mark yeah and
then it and then that took off and then
we started doing more videos in that in
that ilk I have no need to be the guy
like I don't I don't even like being the
guy I'd much rather be the guy behind
the guy you know but
that they're not like I see so much
darkness and so I feel called that I
have to I have to step up but I'd much
rather you do it or somebody else yeah
right so I don't see it as competition
um I'm I like would love to cheer
everybody on and I'm just in the in the
crowd like clapping them up
yeah you know it's funny you you like
you really
um internally like this guy called
Clarence Avon have you ever heard of
Clarence Avon no but I'll look him up
Avant a-v-a-n-t and I'll tell you the
story okay internally like Clarence Avon
but externally because you're looking
around and nobody's doing it you had to
you had to get in front of the camera
right you're like PC Jones so let me let
me tell you why I love Quincy so Quincy
right transform music oh yeah Quincy's
however and and nobody will argue that
Quincy didn't impact a bunch of people
like amazing
Quincy's best friend was a guy named
Clarence Avon
and
influenced probably 100 times more
people in the music industry in politics
than anyone and they did a documentary
on them called the black Godfather
and and his all right and his whole
mission is remind me because this is
where I'm at now like I'm an extra I'm
more of an extrovert but when I came on
the scene and I was making a lot of
difference like some of these doctors or
or the players they wanted they like Deb
you got to be my secret weapon right so
I kind of love that it was the first I
was like the secret weapon wasn't
telling anybody anything nobody said
they were working with me and and I saw
this um documentary called the black
Godfather and and it was about Clarence
Avon he started in the 20s when there's
a lot of racism and and the Italian mob
was like the only black guy they brought
in he learned the industry and he was
the guy who started getting people
knowing about Masters get your masses
right
and if in the beginning he's like hard
he's like they're like What's he's like
What's Love Got to Do With It he's like
if it ain't about the numbers that don't
make it don't make sense that's how it
starts but when you watch the
documentary you realize oh this guy was
all about love like he really was a
bright light and loved people and
interviews from everyone from Smokey
Robinson to Diddy he saved Diddy's life
when he had beef with the West Coast
this is an OG uh Drake Obama said I knew
I had problems when when Clarence didn't
back me and he was back in Hillary
Clinton like he got people elected right
and he was always he never wanted to be
in front of the camera and then they
showed all these Grammy speeches from
all these artists they're like I want to
thank Clarence Avon and and nobody
outside of this world knew that this guy
was this guy so when I saw it
I kind of loved it because I was like
you know what
I want to be like Clarence Avon right
like like behind the scenes I'm the
world is Shifting I got a hand in it
people you know the bright light is it's
kind of like what you're saying like I
want to be the guy behind the guy right
and then eventually like some of my
clients are like Devin why don't more
people know about you man like we we
need your your voice out there in the
world like people need to see you and
also you know there's a lot of people
who think like representations uh you
know one of my favorite game changes was
the guy who came this guy Ted Crawford
and said yo I called my boys
I told them Yo there's a brother there's
a brother doing this content because
usually I go to these things ain't no
Brothers doing the content and if they
are they're doing someone else's stuff
so so like this guy was so excited right
and and it and it brought me out to be
like okay how do I bridge that Gap and
and what I'm hearing from you EV is like
internally you're like Clarence Avon you
want to be like the guy behind the guy
but you know you've embraced kind of
like you Quincy Jones man right like
like you're really out there and leading
the way in many ways right so it's like
how can you you know honor both right I
think you'd love that move like the
documentary it starts a little slow but
I think I think you'll see what I mean
like if there is a power in being the
kind of secret weapon behind people too
but uh I think that you know those days
are not the kind of behind you in many
ways because your voice is so now needed
and Powerful in the world so it's like
how do we how do we amplify that but
also you know honor who you who you are
yeah I mean I struggled a ton with that
and and thank you for the you know I'll
go check out that movie I wrote it down
um
for years the biggest fight I would get
into with my agent is we need your story
we need your stories like Steve I don't
this is New York guy too like I I don't
need it man I don't like it I don't I
don't like I can't wait till I get in
front of the camera again like I don't
light up when that stuff happens
um
so it's a reluctant role in but then
people kept we did these top tens for a
bunch of years right yeah it was the
first one we made a whole bunch of them
and the number one request from the
audience was me
I'm like why do you want me like I built
this old the company but I'm not yay I'm
not Steve Jobs I'm not Oprah I'm not
like we profiled like the the Legends
right yeah it was kept so then my team
so I said we're not doing me that I mean
if it sounds so egotistical and like
whatever what's my story compared
eventually my team uh surprised me on my
birthday and posted one made it and
posted it to my channel without me
knowing on my birthday
[Laughter]
and uh and people liked it and so okay
well I guess I'll do more me so I
recognize now that people learn through
my story as well and I can hit some
people who who other people can't what
I've been focusing on so yes my story
and telling my story still learning from
all these people what you can learn from
their success and then also helping
others so whether it's people who are
already at the top of their game helping
them with their with their YouTube and
getting their message out to the world
or people on the come up you know people
like you who are already experts at
something but may not have as big a
digital footprint or people uh like
movement makers where you came in where
it's like okay I want to be someone like
Devin now I want to have a full-time
business and so I love training those
people and so while that's happening
yeah and I feel great about it like
anytime I look at any of those things I
could feel great and it's like okay and
let's go do more yeah everything you do
on YouTube is extraordinary you could be
giving content out right and then you're
using movement makers is your own
Community right you're teaching people
in the community how to build their
business and things like that we have a
believe Nation Community which is people
who watch my videos movement makers is a
is a people who want to be thought
leaders so it's a much narrow down Focus
like if somebody watches uh one of a
Kanye top 10 video you don't necessarily
want to go be a speaker yeah author or a
coach right so there's a really narrow
part but again like like why I love
doing it is because people can learn
through if I can help some of those
people get their story out people will
learn from them when they won't listen
to me yeah
listen man I love who you are man I love
your mission I think um
you know it could feel lonely it can
feel lonely when you're walking you know
when I tell people best day of my life
and and I mean it like you know I had a
client it was like the difference of
Devin is when he says best day of his
life he means it like he's like that's
it I have about 307 Uber drivers numbers
in my phone wow okay one Uber driver I
had we were talking and the guy he he
looked like Neo you ever you know like
Neil like
dressed in a suit he had this he had
like a Civic but it was like tricked out
with lights in right he's picking me up
taking me to the airport he opens the
door most amazing experience I'm like
hey man tell me his story and he's like
yeah well you know I was raised by
um women and and I want to start this
clothing line where we're bringing
gentlemen like being a gentleman is is
the mission like bringing there's not
enough gentlemen in the world I'm like
yo I love that so I'm listening to him I
said well you know this is what I do
with people you know are you opening
some some suggestions right I want to
ask permission and he goes like this he
goes yeah all right like
like this like like it's not so I go I
say oh never mind right never mind so so
it just gets quiet
so we're gonna know now my phone rings
and it's one of the the guy the teams
like General magic calls me and I'm on
the phone and I'm coaching them through
something really quick on the phone on
the right so he must be hearing and
saying oh this guy this guy knows what
he's talking about right I hang up he
says no no no I want that suggestion I
said nah man listen what what is this
like where else in your world are you
saying something's important but then
when there's an opportunity you just
kind of like what and he's like no
you're right
he thinks we're on the in the fourth
Lane on the ho v Lane the dude drives
all the way to the other side of the
Parkway off the off the Parkway and
stops the car and says hey man I really
wanna I'm here I'm locked in I'm
listening
so it was amazing we create something
with him and then he sent me a picture
two months later I I gave him some
um
coaching on it he brought me to the
airport and followed up and the guy
moved to Louisiana and opened up like
this a gentleman clothing uh uh brand
and you know is doing well but there was
another guy to our conversation these
are like Uber drivers that I I have
these conversations every day because I
don't I don't drive so I create with
people every day
but I had a guy he had like a um this
dude had a Maga hat right and I got
friends who are Maga the dude I think he
had one of the
um Confederate flags right on on the
back of the truck like so I got in the
car and I'm like hey man what's up like
best day of my life and upgrade with him
and it's all good like
I don't care what you believe so the
guy's real tight right so so he starts
talking F and he's like and you know how
like people are talking but they're like
subtly throwing bombs they're like yeah
this country you know real negative like
when when this one was in and now this
one's in and this wokes aside like he's
he's doing the whole thing right wanting
like the reaction and I'm just like man
well well let me tell me more man like
that must be difficult like you know so
I'm just listening I'm asking questions
and the guy keeps talking talking and
and I said well while you open like I I
could see your point of view I totally
see you know where you're coming from
like you think that people are taking
over the world's pushing you out I get
it right and I say well are you open to
another point of view I'm not saying Eve
is right wrong good or bad it's like
let's talk right let's just let's talk
because I believe that you know one of
the problems today is people have not
learned to disagree without being
disagreeable right it's like we got to
make someone wrong for us to be right
and actually two people can be right at
the same time they just got a different
point of view right people can look at
this guy and say this and that so we
talked Eva I swear to God the guy so we
get to the airport the guy comes out big
guy
and says yo man can I give you a hug
and the dude gives me a hug and the
dude's like crying like like crying I'm
like what he's like
you don't realize man you I've never
been listened to the way you've listened
to me man and and you gave me some
things to think about and I just want to
thank you right and to me
like that ain't gonna make it on YouTube
or that ain't gonna make it on TV but
like and I know you have interactions
with people all the time too we don't
want to Discount how we're making the
world better in those ways too in the
quiet ways you know what I'm saying 100
and like listen like I live
98 of the time in that yeah it's like I
touch that person's life it's amazing
and listen as I'm hearing you tell that
story your story with that guy the first
guy who was opened up his shop the
tailor it's like I wish that was on
YouTube it's like it's not discounting
anything that I do
because honestly dude like you mentioned
lonely I don't feel lonely like I'm
introvert I have if I have Nina my wife
I'm good I don't need to go to any
conference or networking covid was great
you know it's like me and Nina at home
like no problem this is fantastic right
like people fell apart it was great for
us it's perfect if I lost her my world
would would crumble so like that's a
whole other thing but uh as long as I
have Nina like I'm good
and it would be easy for me just to sit
back and say uh I'm I'm like I'm kicking
ass and I'm helping people and if you
saw the comments every day and the DMS
every day I actually find it easier to
get lost in the one-on-ones I could do
one-on-ones all day long yeah and it's
so fulfilling to see that you helped
that one person yeah uh I just feel like
I'm it's not enough for what I'm capable
of and and I need to be out there doing
more so I have to push myself to go do
that I could very easily just be a coach
or uh investor or whatever
um it's my maybe it's my mom's voice who
kept saying if you have the ability to
have the responsibility you know I was
like you can therefore you must and I
don't use it as a beat down like I'm not
sitting here saying
I suck like why am I not doing better
and not have an appliance like no my
life is awesome and it's great and I'm
capable of more so what can I do
and if you wish BS by the way like call
it out and and let me know you know
listen I'm with you and this is the
thing see whenever I hit a ceiling with
with clients or myself right I always
what we want to do is recognize the
ceiling acknowledge it hey you did great
you reached this next Milestone and then
I'll say EV can you get that
acknowledgment you'll say Dev yeah I can
get it and now the work is okay now
we're gonna make that the floor
right so we reach the ceiling we
acknowledge how far we've come we make
that to Florida right and that's our new
floor we create what's next from that I
think that there's a a gift in that
because most people are high performance
they're 80 percent looks like most
people's a hundred percent and to me
that's what what what chips away at to
me when I know that I'm at 80 and I'm
not giving 100 I can't stay there
because it chips away in my spiritual
condition right like I feel like I'm
cheating the world so and I hear that in
you you know and and that's why I like
connect with you so much because I do
think that there's a lot of people doing
really good stuff but they know they
only given the 80 and and they're kind
of resting on not that it's good bad
right or wrong it's just that I'm not
built like that right yeah which is
wrong for us that's all yeah yeah so you
go do you that's it so when my clients
or people like all right Dev listen I
hear you you've been the black offer but
like can we get you out there now to the
world uh I I am like you know I feel
like it's the time maybe it's the time
and continue to live how we live every
day you know as much as I like being out
in rooms I'm like you like I love space
and quiet man walked on the beach with
my wife this morning got some quiet time
even in our home she knows like we spent
a lot of time but she also like he needs
a space too
and and I enjoy that too so I'm kind of
like a mixer like most people say I'm in
I don't go into extra in in enter
because I'm kind of both when at all at
all times so and what's my homework what
am I working on I'm going to watch the
black Godfather and what I want you to
do is really start to think the number
you have right the 35 million is the
number right I want you to go to that
place and just look from that place of
what is now possible okay what is now
possible with you know who you being in
this place uh what's the what's
accessible that isn't accessible now and
and because we want to start pulling
that future into the present we don't
want to wait till then to do it so I
want you to create that place from the
third like I've touched 35 million that
we have the subscribers this is what's
going on in my world this is what it's
giving me access to this is who I'm
being uh this is what I'm doing and I
want you to like we're gonna reverse
engineer it from there you know how you
feeling at this moment how are you
celebrating this you know I'm inviting
Dev to Canada where you know we we have
a real dope house party whatever it is
let's go I want you to to go to that
place and then we'll we'll look back and
create from there okay watch the black
Godfather yep and I want you to uh see
what you like about how he showed up and
created in the world
and and how you want to be maybe
different or take what he learned and
to another level okay Quincy Jones had
one of my greatest uh there's a great
line he said I mean he's got lots of
great quotes but not one drop of myself
worth uh depends on your opinion of me
yeah beautiful thing I like it all right
last last homework assignment you're
gonna do this is gonna be only three
weeks and the goal of this assignment
is not to get caught up in
it's it's kind of like watching your
thoughts from a neutral place it's not
going to be about like oh I got this low
grade thought and I want to like just
you know just stay in it right it's just
I want to watch it from neutral I want
you to start capturing
your like any low-grade thoughts that
come
just capture them
write them down
you know oh this is taking too long uh
you know my voice isn't hitting enough
people uh you know this person doesn't
appreciate whatever it is you want to
capture it and we're going to do
something with that work now the key to
that is don't get caught up it's just
I'm just saying two places
I'm the Observer oh that came up yeah
but what you'll see is you'll notice
there'll be some stuff that comes up
once more than you thought there'll be
stuff there that you didn't even think
was there and we'll play with that and
and is this meant to be a passive
exercise or or you want like a focused
work on it
I want you some do some focused work
because we're trying to do some real
work what we're going to do is we're
going to capture the patterns right it's
like GPS
you know it's like if I put 300 Green
Street in my head I'm gonna end up at
300 Green Street if I put you know 1200
Waters Place I'm gonna end up at 1200
Waters Place and so even these
subconscious thoughts of oh this isn't
happening fast enough I put that in my
GPS it's going to end up at not
happening fast enough so what we want to
do is we want to capture these so we can
clear them out there's a process I'll do
with you and then we'll recreate on top
of that
we'll clean it out rewire and that
that'll be the Practical process to the
video you sent me like how do we do that
first we gotta capture all the low grade
thoughts
okay
done let's go all right okay I just
finished with Devin and he gave me three
pieces of homework and I thought as a
little change to how I normally make
content I'm gonna bring you guys behind
the scenes of me actually doing the work
that people assign me to do so the three
bits of homework from Devon were one I
need to think about me from having 35
million subscribers and what does life
look like and so I'm gonna do I guess a
little meditative or journaling exercise
to figure out what that looks like for
me two we gotta watch the black
Godfather and I gotta see where where
that exists if I can get it on Netflix
or I have to download it or or find it
hopefully it's accessible and three is
to watch my negative thoughts what do
they call it low grade thoughts and so
again a separate meditation or
journaling session thinking about my low
grade thoughts and I'm gonna do them now
well not like right now but some of them
right now because I don't want to wait I
don't want to wait I don't want to wait
I'm gonna take you guys a little bit
behind the scenes to watch me do it too
see if you like it so Step One is let's
look up black Godfather
this is an easy one I guess black
Godfather
2019 documentary two hours long Al
Capone was a cast
wow this is the guy Clarence Avant and
watch the black Godfather on Netflix all
right great well we're gonna we're gonna
be watching that soon let's learn a
little bit about clients have won 92
years old died in 2021 so he just passed
away well he lived a long life and let's
go dive in on his story okay Nina
it just made it worse okay
he's now gonna
go Scott and a half now it's gone is it
my fault yeah it is your fault well you
know what it's really Devin bandison's
fault I just finished the call with him
he gave me some homework okay one of the
homework is I need to watch a movie
called The Black Godfather and take some
notes okay it's apparently on Netflix
okay so we're gonna watch it
and we could both take notes
okay okay okay Showtime
we're doing our homework
homework we've been watching sweet tooth
so far so good the first one there yeah
yeah the black Godfather all right there
it is
boom let's watch
so just finished watching the black
Godfather great recommendation I took
two pages of notes and thought it would
come down here to record some of my
quick thoughts while it's still fresh
let me show you my notes I like to write
in these big notebooks and then this is
I did a good job to try to make it
actually legible and my handwrite is not
always legible when I'm in a rush to
take notes and I write it down I had two
pages here we'll go over it quickly and
I do it and then I look it over and
digest it and then action action it ties
it so these are just ideas and quotes
that came up to me and then I have to
put these into actions and maybe I'll
talk with Devin about it afterwards so
the black Godfather he puts people
together and they do what they do so one
of the main themes here is he's a
connector he knows a ton of people he's
a connector he loves introducing people
to each other he built a light by
putting people together his tool is
knowing how to manipulate people but not
in a bad way so helping them act in
everybody's self-interest he knew
everybody he was a celebrity celebrity
he finds Common Ground between people
who are different so I'm writing some of
these
you know I can connect to something like
this like finding common ground between
people who are different I can
definitely connect to that I don't know
that I know everybody or I'm the
celebrity celebrity you know I think I
think that's very generous maybe Devin
sees something to me that I don't yet
see in myself and we'll talk more about
that but um yeah it was that was
definitely fun he's a historian and a
maker of History I like that I love
studying success and and have Ambitions
to make history too I don't make
speeches I make deals with one of his
quotes So I prefer to be behind the
scenes making deals and introing people
than to make big speeches and as an
introvert I can definitely connect to
that he absorbed the best of everybody
he saw this was a big one for me I
learned from everybody all the people
that I profile on my channel I've
learned something from and
you know even somebody you hate you can
still learn something from them and so
that was I mean that I really like that
message there he can connect with
everyone and he did I don't know that I
can connect with everyone I think on a
human level I can maybe I'm still a
little shy to do it but
um definitely aspirational uh nobody
understands what his official title was
I love that because I don't know what my
official title is Clarence was a guy you
had to see to put certain kinds of deals
together so for that one I uh I love
studying business plans and I love
studying how people are successful in
businesses and I and because of studying
business clients I can often make
connections between different
opportunities and different industries
that most people don't see and so that
part when I saw that I was like okay I
see you Devin I see you there's
something here for sure this one was
great I don't have problems I have
friends so I think I could do a better
job of of calling on my friends when I
have problems I'd like my path to 35
million subscribers I should probably
call my friends more uh he said he's not
going to follow a script not going to do
what's expected which I definitely agree
with he gave people a platform to help
them make a big leap forward and so this
was another one that I really connected
with and that he's trying to put people
on he's trying to Showcase people it's
what I'm trying to do with movement
makers and people in my masterminds like
the next generation of thought leaders
up and coming spreading a message
message of Hope and positivity and the
people we profile and all the training
that I'm trying to do is people may not
learn from my voice but they might be
able to learn from yours and so that's
what I try to teach inside mover makers
and I just love the idea of putting
people on and teaching them the skills
to be successful especially in this
business because your message can touch
somebody in a way that I can't so people
said he had a feel for what wasn't being
done at the time this one resonated
because like I was telling Devin there's
so much negativity right now there's so
much the world is ending right now
there's so much economic collapse right
now there's so much AI is going to kill
us all right now and that's what seems
to be prevalent at the time and I just
see things a different way I think it's
the greatest time to be alive ever and
so I see it a different way and I need
my voice to be louder he has the ability
to walk into a room and tell people
exactly what they needed to hear I've
been told that I need to do that more
but uh definitely agree with that one
and equality drives him he wants to see
people win that was page one let's
quickly go through page two uh he put on
a giant five-day Music Festival when
Martin Luther King died called it save
the children it was the biggest ever
music event for black music I love that
it was just a product of the the time
and one of the things that I struggle
with is how do I or do I
be more culture relevant with news I
don't really follow the news I don't
like the news I think the news is very
negative so do I put myself in the
middle of news stories and spread a
message of Hope and positivity and
belief or do I just
do I just keep doing what I'm doing you
know that's one of the things I keep
thinking about so um
Clarence seemed to put himself
in the moment and so it's definitely
something that I can get better at as a
deal maker he was the best in the
business you know I love studying
business models but I don't know that
I'm the best deal maker so it could be a
hidden opportunity for me uh he mixed
worlds Got Musicians to perform to
support politicians he pulled most of
Hollywood together to support Jimmy
Carter so mixing music and politicians
uh he got Hank Aaron the biggest brand
deal with Coca-Cola ever he gave people
the first real shots I love that he
never looked for permission uh Diddy
said Clarence made sure you didn't get
f'd in your deals he was an advocate for
the creative people he helped people in
their lives too he was the guy you
called when you were in trouble he
wanted everyone to do better and then
this one really this is the last quote I
wrote down David Geffen who was a legend
in the music industry said I don't know
how he made a living he never used to
charge for anything and that quote stuck
with me because the last time I was
hanging with the people in in the
thought leader business in Napa close to
Brendan Bouchard's house
at our Round Table I asked for help of
you guys know me what's my blind spot
and for the next 20 minutes Brendan
Bouchard Dean grezio see Tom bilyu and
Lisa bilyu all kind of laid into me to
say you give so much and you help so
much and we don't know how to pay you we
don't know what your business is we
don't know how to get you paid tell us
how we can pay you
I was like I don't know I don't wanna
it's fine like I love helping and
serving so when David said that I don't
know how he made a living he never used
to charge for anything there's
definitely some magic there and
it made me feel
not as weird
yeah because the feedback coming out of
that group was they don't know what I do
or how I get paid and as if as if they
should and that was that should be
something I focus more on and that left
feeling like uh I don't know I don't
know that I I don't know that I do
so it's confirmation I guess that uh one
of the most successful men behind the
scenes in the music world politics
Hollywood
Etc people didn't know what he did
either okay so task number two is
complete I still have task number one
and task number three to do number one
was I need to imagine myself having
reached the goal and imagine what that
feels like and write down who I am and
who I'm impacting and and the things
that I'm doing so I'm going to do a
meditation session or sitting outside
tomorrow and see what comes up and I'll
bring you on the journey and then task
number three was I need to keep track of
my feel what do you call it that
limiting thoughts but negative thoughts
are low level thoughts I'll get the
exact word in so next couple days I'm
gonna get those done I'm gonna take you
on the journey with me and
see what I discover all right it is the
next day which means I'm doing more
homework from Devin today today is a
Sunday as I'm filming this and on
Sundays I usually spend a couple hours
reviewing my notes from conferences or
books or
rereading things and just planning and
so I'm going to use that time today to
work on homework number one which was
what does 35 million subscribers look
like tastes like feel like
and I'm just gonna see what comes up
take some notes
you posted
[Music]
okay let's take a look at what I wrote
down so what is 35 million subscribers
feel like started with being an
important part of people's daily routine
if I think about the channel right now
it is an important part of a lot of
people's daily lives but it could be
more important is it the most important
part of somebody's
routine is it a must do every day to get
their mindset right and for some people
yes for a lot of people not yet so I've
got some work to do I put in being able
to put people on and give exposure being
able to open bigger doors that have a
bigger impact traveling more and
spreading a message around the world I
travel a lot but it's been mostly to the
US I'm in the U.S twice a month uh where
you know this could be a lot more global
Ripple effects in the culture fashion
politics entertainment and Sports making
imagine practical that one's from John
Lennon you know the song Imagine imagine
all the people living life in peace you
know you may say I'm a dreamer but I'm
not the only one and it's like how do
you take that message and make it
practical and and make it help you know
entrepreneurs but the world
gonna go down that path creating a real
Community for people the family they
need and never had bringing more people
together instead of pushing them apart
making it okay for people to suck at the
start launching products that people
will proudly wear and use symbols of
identity partnering with Titans outside
of thought leadership and I've helped
almost everybody basically thought
leadership so now you know it's time to
expand beyond that uh being a bigger
unifier creating easier programs for
people to follow more step by step
spending less time on smaller projects
and tasks give responsibilities away to
people sooner
uh being better at capturing the magic
that happens one-on-one being better a
personal brand storytelling and a lot of
this is what I'm currently doing just
bigger faster and better what I realized
in looking at that list is I'm already
doing this stuff you know I'm already
doing it on but on a smaller scale and
and smaller scale you know I mean it's
I'm grateful for everything that I've
been able to accomplish and we're
hitting way more people now than I was
five years ago or ten years ago and it's
easy for me to sit there in gratitude
and and a lot of this stuff is just
doing this on a bigger scale
getting it done faster and being better
at it and so I'm looking at the list I
don't know anything pops off yet from
the page of this is the major
breakthrough or this is the big shift
that I have to make
it's uh
I'm already doing a lot of this stuff
[Music]
but I'm still playing small compared to
what I could be doing
and this list is a good starting point
there's a Clues to
push faster
I love these thought exercises
okay it is time to complete my
three-part Challenge from Devin and this
is the one that I am least looking
forward to which is to monitor my low
grade thinking I think that's what I
said low grade thinking low grade
thoughts so I'm coming to my basement
because we are gonna go in here this is
my Sana
and it is
well it is a combination of infrared
red light therapy grounding matte and
EMF protection and it is going to get
very hot in here so I figured I'm gonna
sit on that stool and torture myself in
the Heat and torture myself with my
thoughts and hopefully come out with
some serious low grade thoughts
so I can complete my homework okay I
just had a really hard Simon followed by
a really cold shower and let's see what
I came up with I I had to tear the page
out of the book because it was getting
all crinkly from the sweat and the heat
in the community and listen this was
actually really hard and this is maybe
something I'll talk to Devin the next
time that I I talk to him because
as soon as I had any kind of negative
thought first I had to really force
myself to go negative like okay you hate
yourself this is terrible you know I had
to like really try to try to go to a
dark place because I don't live in
low-grade thoughts and then anytime I
came up with one I instantly said yeah
but this and went to the positive like
automatically and
I think that's a good thing and I
probably trained it uh in myself over
the years I didn't used to be like that
so every single negative thought that I
came up with even when I forced it
automatically had a positive response
afterwards uh but that that's not so
helpful when you're trying to uncover
low-grade thoughts uh so let me share
with you what I forced myself to come up
with okay low great thoughts I'm not
growing fast enough I'm not making
enough of an impact the plant isn't
working I don't know what to do people
won't help me I won't figure this out I
can't get people to care people come for
the celebs not my contribution I haven't
mobilized my subscribers my content is
not important enough I can't pull this
off I'm not bold enough to do this I'm
not taking the actions fast enough the
dark is more powerful than the light I'm
not bringing enough value and I'm stuck
and then even look at this and and me
reading it back it feels gross like no I
don't like any of these things and I
come with Solutions right away for all
of these things but um anyway I have
finished my homework assignments so we
did all three things he told me to do we
watch the black Godfather I came up with
what 35 million subscribers feels like
and then I came up with my list of low
grade thoughts I'm going to submit my
homework to Devin see what he says and
then maybe we do a round two and one
last request this is a new format that
I'm trying out that might tell me why I
suck Series where I bring somebody on
they tell me why I suck and then I take
you a little bit behind the scenes of
the things that I'm doing afterwards as
a result of the advice that they gave me
so if you want the interview to just end
uh amazing let me know in the comments
and if you want to see me and the
homework I'm doing and what I'm learning
and applying in this Vlog style it takes
obviously a lot more work to do this so
if you like it let me know in the
comments and I might keep it up to see
the amazing training Devin gave my
movement maker students check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe I'll see you
there Kobe Bryant when he retired he
told his daughters he said if you get
this you'll have a successful life and
he had all his his trophies he had all
his accolades and he said this isn't the
dream he said the dream was waking up
5am